all right now I have to talk about
something anybody who saw our program
last night is going to demand that I
discuss this because something happened
in the middle of our show last night
just after we came back from commercial
and I've been doing this show a long
time and in all the many years I've been
doing late-night something like this has
never happened before it was real we
didn't think of this or contrived it
this just happened I think you can tell
when you see the look on my face that
something real and strange is unfolding
check out this clip from our show last
night I want to mention something fall
TV shows we're back on the Internet
swear to God we've been doing this show
for over 14 years I have never heard
this sound before but everyone stay calm
what is that all about Jeff do they know
we're taping
Klingons approaching
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a New York subway we should just
enter this thing the way it is and let
the people out there know how crappy
this show is run
[Applause]
so we just aired you know we just aired
the show as it all happened last night
and all of us were stunned I didn't I
was thinking how could this happen this
must be a professional broadcast but my
biggest question is who's that guy
making the announcement and he came back
later in the in the next segment when I
was talking to paget Brewster the the
second guest he came back and made more
announcements well anyway it turns out
everything was fine it was a false alarm
but this morning I had this burning idea
I wanted to grab a camera crew and
investigate and meet the guy that made
that announcement so I went downstairs
here's what happened take a look hi how
are you good to see you
you are are you Bruce yes i bruce Britt
yes and what is your title you're the
fire safety director this is your
station right here
you made an announcement yesterday
around I'm gonna say around 6 o'clock in
the evening is that right well we were
we were taping a show were you aware of
that
yeah and your announcement actually
interrupted our show and and was heard
by probably three million viewers can we
recreate that announcement right now can
we hear it just as you said it okay may
I have your attention please may I have
your attention this is a fire safety
director speaking we have received an
alarm condition on the fifth floor
building personnel are conducting an
investigation at this time
please stand by for further instructions
it went out to three million let's bump
that up and went out to 15 million
viewers last night I'm including
Telemundo Silencio Silencio
una done jor-el so predicament oh I
think it was on Telemundo your voice is
very good you ever if I just came up
with some announcements would you do
those sure okay I repeat I repeat there
are onions on the griddle onions on the
griddle put on your Admirals hat there
are onions on the griddle there are
onions on the griddle
there are onions on a griddle I repeat
there are onions on the grill put on
your handle set your onions on a griddle
there are onions on the griddle that
sounds pretty good try this one talent
alert talent alert there's a talent
overload Conan O'Brien is in the
building
talent
it's Alan alert talent alert there's a
talent overload in the building Conan
O'Brien is in the building yes I love
that thing this console over here we're
the scripted announcements right to the
right of us you tell me what you think
of my voice if you think I'd be any good
at this
all right try it in my voice what which
one should I use right here okay check
this out
hey there may I have your attention
please this is your fire safety director
we have a wrong condition on the fifth
floor investigation if you would even go
higher we can work with that before
really yeah it sounded horrible look at
this one right here okay odors speak
slowly calmly and clearly can you read
that one for us okay may I be attention
please
this is a fire safety director speaking
we are experiencing a smell odor or
smoke condition from outside of our
building this is due to construction
work repair work for other although we
are adjusting or other kind of leaves it
out there right the odor might be
it could be a lot of things you know
true Oh
what's that what happened what's going
on Oh what happened that's somebody's
just somebody's working upstairs that's
all it just lets me know that somebody's
working on wanted devices my heart just
stopped for a second all right you're
good did you go you're gonna be take
care of me I got you
I feel everything's good she'll say yes
all right I have a hug please you know
what but hadn't happened we never would
have met that's true yeah I think it's
nice that we met Bruce brick
I'm doing good now a Bruce Bruce is
going to help take us out to commercial
tonight Bruce take it away
may I have your attention may I have
your attention please
we'll be right back but our first guest
Jake Gyllenhaal